a Buddhist Abbott from Taiwan at a
meditation center in southern Germany
here Taiwanese and Germans practice Zen
meditation together the teachings of the
Buddha are becoming increasingly popular
in Europe
no wonder says German Lutheran
theologian and Zen instructor Michelle
Phan work with globalization the world
has become more close-knit cultures are
influencing each other and religions as
well seasonal marlins exactly is our
religions are part of our historical
legacy of the image they are the
shoulders we stand on they have shaped
our languages are art and of course the
images of our spiritual lives so it
comes it to them today they are coming
together in there are other Asians and
Europeans don't just meet in the
marketplace but also in family life in
meditation and in art maybe with your
kindle and these encounters will give
rise to a new culture it will take
centuries maybe thousands of years but
the process has already begun yep I
wasn't it love with Yun fingers in
toronto's in
Venice the queen of the Adriatic
Serenissima for centuries the wealthy
metropolis was a hub of European trade
where Orthodox Christians from the east
mingled with Roman Catholics none of
them could overlook the fact that their
traditions varied
there isn't just one Christian faith
says Michelle Phan work Christianity has
evolved and changed in various periods
of history like Buddhism Michelle Phan
work is here to conduct a seminar at the
International University of Venice he
officially retired last month but he's
still passionate about mediating between
Christianity and Buddhism as it has in
the middle of the whole patient Kishida
performed as much as Illinois lease up
that they sell a minority convicted
Kirsten Buddhist masami Island
historically Christianity and Buddhism
are similar in the way they spread both
red spelled from the countries in which
they originated Buddhism virtually died
out in India but it spread to the west
and to the east Christianity also spread
eastward and westward one of the first
in fact it spread east right from the
beginning that's something we are
inclined to forget in Europe it spread
to Syria and Mesopotamia giving rise to
the county and Christians cousin be that
and then to China's ended on the flight
of Christianity reached China very early
certainly by the fifth or the sixth
century and have come into contact with
Buddhism with impetus was in contact
become michelin work was born in 1949
the son of a Lutheran pastor for him the
road to faith was music he was a
chorister in the famous Dresden Boys
Choir
later he studied Lutheran theology and
Indian culture and languages and won a
scholarship to visit India from there he
traveled to Japan and immersed himself
for years in the spiritual world of
Indian religions and japanese zen
buddhism on meeting the dalai lama he
was introduced to tibetan buddhism the
two men are still in contact michelle
phan work feels at home in both
traditions in christianity as well as
Buddhism they've been valent the curse
of the other Buddhist I'm on the road to
becoming a Christian and to becoming a
buddhist the deeper i study buddhist
practice the better i understand the
depths of christianity d-fenders customs
better and when I experienced the debts
of Christianity I understand Buddhism
better Buddhist was this is one bad day
it's like mountaineering when you climb
a chimney and communes died you hold on
to one side and climb the other then you
always have to have two feet and a hand
or two hands and a foot firmly anchored
vest on then the remaining hand or foot
relaxes and moves up in the diva that's
the feeling I have with Christianity and
Buddhism the deeper I immerse myself in
the one religion the more I experience
of the other and vice versa or longer
cable there are relatively few Buddhists
in Germany but every major city has a
number of Buddhist centers and
meditation groups
however people who think that a bit of
Buddhist meditation will help them cope
better with stress are on the wrong
track the aim of Buddhism is not to
strengthen the ego but to free us from
it
meditation should help us not to take
ourselves too seriously giving us the
freedom to experience compassion for
others that's an idea it has in common
with Christianity
Domitia tertia honest nismo in buddhism
in many cultures not just in buddhism
meditation is a way of arriving at a
profound experience of consciousness
literally experiencing that all the
thoughts feelings perceptions intuitions
of the individual ego are transient a
woman may soon disappear that I ignant
ugly but beyond this transients is an
attentiveness I can't put it any
differently that's our hindered is a [ __ ]
English code I know old Mac a wakeful
state of consciousness that is always
there hide this bubble sounds leaked de
mother the goal of Buddhism is to
experience that dear this Buddhist
Buddhists call it nirvana nirvana one
literally it means exhaling the ego it's
something beyond the ego is that it
isn't the ego that constantly wants to
be stable and passes and decays it's
something beyond that I was a stay in
Billy's and the goal is to gain
spiritual attentiveness so as to
experience that which is beyond all
transients does is to steer Buddhism
evolved about two and a half thousand
years ago in northern India based on the
teachings of Siddhartha Gautama who was
called Buddha the enlightened one
we're told that he dedicated his life to
overcoming human suffering the cause of
the constant cycle of suffering appeared
to him to lie in our wishes and desires
we're unhappy because we're always
wishing for something when we no longer
desire anything we no longer suffer
to realize this Buddhists don't need God
human beings can achieve their own
salvation by seeking truth and happiness
in themselves that's what Buddhism
encourages us to do the position of the
hand means do not fear the Buddhists are
hurting Oh the Buddhist approach which
doesn't need a Creator God is attractive
to many people in the modern world
because it seems compatible with science
but that's not essential it's just a
theory or deform is the important thing
for spiritual practice for meditation is
the question how do I experience more
deeply aside from all theoretical
concepts and on that level Buddhists and
Christians can not only understand each
other but can stimulate each other yeah
Kings adesh Timoleon
since Peter's Cathedral in the Bavarian
town of regensburg the tower saws a
hundred and five meters the nave is more
than 10 meters high this is one of the
most impressive churches in Germany for
people in the Middle Ages Gothic
cathedrals were an image of paradise
with their super natural beauty they
pointed to the heavenly Jerusalem in
which the Savior will rain at the end of
time
much has changed and evolved over 2,000
years in the history of Christianity
however certain key aspects were viewed
as immutable from the start and still
are they constitute the essence of the
faith the central truth of Christianity
is that God loves human beings he didn't
hide in a distant heaven but became
human in Jesus of Nazareth he is one of
us for Christians Jesus is the way to
God we can know God through him there's
a famous work of sculpture in regensburg
Cathedral that beautifully portrays this
connection between God and humans
Felicia and simpler for me a central
aspect of Christianity is the
incarnation of God his becoming human he
got the hit neck that means divine
energy the Spirit of God is present in
the world and takes form in humans
Rafael de that is wonderfully expressed
herein regensburg Cathedral through the
angel of the Annunciation for
kindergarten and Gabriel is smiley
delivered his message is one that raises
a smile something wonderful and gentle
childless well then we see in the figure
of Mary the joyful receptiveness he's a
bit i trough Mary's left hand is opened
up words a book is lying in it you can't
go earth not know that is the message I
boo this is the deep boy draft other
hand expresses the characteristic
attitude thankful do not fear which we
also saw in the Buddha's got the histor
so the divine is not something
terrifying it's powerful but God is
perceived to be the creator of heaven
and earth and therefore beyond human
understanding that he assumes a delicate
form the smile and the do not be afraid
correspond to each other correspond via
there is nay co between the divine in
the human surgeon they've got clicking
on dimensionally
it's not just in the architecture of
their churches that Christians praise
God's creation western music and
Christian faith are inextricable
for more than a thousand years one of
the world's most famous boys choirs has
Sun in this Cathedral the Hagins bahador
hudson composers have placed their
talents in the service of God as in this
Sanctus which praises God's holiness
holy holy holy they sing Lord God of
hosts heaven and earth are full of your
glory blessed is he who comes in the
name of the road hosanna in the highest
uh
Oh
music can salmon music can express as a
unity what we in language and thought
can only express as opposites joy and
suffering for instance what we have just
heard in the Sanctus the one hand
something shy and reserved it's
impossible to put it into words it's
something beyond our comprehension in
Flickr for fiddlin and on the other hand
this exultation I am part of the whole
and the divine is in me in mere
michelle phan burke says that the deep
experience to which buddhists aspire in
Zen meditation can be expressed like
this the human consciousness is like an
ocean whose surface is ruffled by waves
the waves are our thoughts and feelings
and when the surface is disturbed by
waves you can't see the bottom of the
ocean that's our normal state of
consciousness only when the
consciousness becomes calm does the
surface also become calm and then you
can look right down to the bottom of the
ocean
of course it's not enough to understand
this intellectually that's why every
school of Buddhism stresses the need for
regular meditation the Zen courses
MichellePhan Burke offers in Bavaria are
always booked out munch [ __ ] said Maria
Gonzales you sense yourself completely
differently in the hectic world of
everyday life you work and study and
have no time for yourself no rest but
here it's wonderful when you learn to go
into yourself and focus on very simple
things maybe does a human like how food
tastes against bananas a consequence
impunity how it feels to walk and how it
sounds in the forest we heard that have
I done those experiences are rare in the
city vini cut we've been something
though I am a seeker I am looking for
something and I sense that I can find it
in myself the more i am in myself the
more lovingly i can deal with what's
outside of me i would say that is what
motivates me
people who wish to discover Buddhism are
all looking for something similar all in
their own way it's the experience that
all religions promise answers to the
questions where do I come from where am
I going what's the meaning of my life
this is gentle Santa's in that it's
interesting that when Europeans were
first drawn to Buddhism in the late 19th
century they were looking for a rational
faith a religion without miracles
without inexplicable connections
ultimately what they were looking for
was a rational psychology so and that's
how they perceived Buddhism it isn't
perceived that way in Asia but that's
how europeans viewed it then after the
first world war and even more after the
second people longed for silence for
introspection for meditation and they
adopted these aspects which was strongly
developed in Buddhism and learned from
them
meditation and silence are also part of
the Christian tradition and both death
and suffering are important aspects of
Christianity the fundamental Christian
belief is that beyond all suffering
stands a God who loves us
unconditionally
this fundamental experience has a symbol
you find the image in churches of all
denominations throughout the world
including this one on a small Venetian
island
it's the sign of Christianity itself
those coins dusts in the cross is the
main symbol of Christianity the
universal symbol of suffering but Laden
but this suffering does not occur
outside of God and the divine order did
so I God God Himself enters the
suffering takes it upon himself and
reconcile suffering with alcohol
suffering is lifted up into the divine
dimension and thereby overcome woods and
that is the meaning of the cross in
Christianity and here in this church we
have this cross on a blue background
it's not the cross on an orb but it is
standing on a fruit which it is growing
out of its than the fourth that is not
reasonable that's a fascinating symbol
that's a cross that is to say the
liberation the salvation the
reconciliation with God grows out of the
fruit that we know asleep it grows like
new life and the fruit is a pomegranate
which has lots of little seeds they
represent the diversity in the world
which is united in the cross of Christ
and brought as it were to God in the
heavenly spheres and fascinatingly that
is also symbolized here by the star
above the cross it represents the cosmic
dimension the stars in heaven always
symbolized the world order which we
sense behind all the disorder beyond all
the suffering everything is subsumed
into the heavenly order of the stars log
down there God is the ruler of the
universe just as he is the ruler of
human destiny of everything bearing
fruit in new life it's a wonderful
symbol
God sends his son Jesus Christ into the
world he saves human beings from their
sins and suffering by dying on the cross
he gives them new eternal life
continuing after death in Buddhist
practice we have to lose something the
attachment to our own wishes and desires
for these are what give rise to
suffering it's only when we break out of
the endless cycle and give up our ego
Christians would say when we love others
as we love ourselves that we can
understand ourselves as part of a great
totality that outlasts death
this is naguru bunk oh it's a good
exercise when you get older and closer
to death to realize that you can let go
with material things it's NBD everyone
follows their path and now i am
following mine and it's heading towards
death these moments these exercises are
a kind of preparation for letting go of
life like the loss to loosen this
hospice for the dying and terminally ill
is part of the meditation center in
bavaria on their final journey the
patients are cared for in the spirit of
Buddhism when you are dying a spirit of
renunciation can be helpful yeah the
help man does this seem bad you know we
are here the aim is to depart as
peacefully as possible it was tilled
what matters is each moment yes right
now to experience it calmly thankfully
for the Sun for the people who are here
for the fellowship each moment we sit
there and meditate and we think of you
convince pansies loiter good they can
see ya in desert
i'm kashering like
the hospice staff thing for the patient
words of a Lutheran pastor it's not
religion that's important in the face of
death but being there for each other
here is in recession so jealous year we
have a Christian background we meditate
with michelle phan work and practice sin
you've been but that's not essential in
this hospice need everything in the same
house here we're open to all religions
and philosophies to everybody who comes
to us via cold but isn't the teaching of
the Buddha helps us to overcome fear and
sufferings between Duke amongst that's
important to us recognizing this reality
was Victor sphere arrogantly it is a
Berkeley Schneider Kenan
michelle phan park views Christianity
and Buddhism has to spiritual languages
influenced by their respective cultures
each of them explains human existence in
its own way Mike wonderful I thought you
might say that Christianity emphasizes
suffering being overcome from outside by
universal power and integrated integral
in Buddhism suffering is overcome and
integrated by the spiritual experience
of meditation by both cases it is
overcome but differently two languages
ultimately they both lead the Lutheran
pastor and Zen instructor Michelle Phan
work to the core of what religion can
mean for him that is love vente libre
cuates when God's la fills me I'm a new
person when God loves me it's as if this
love passes through me it continues I'm
held within a cycle and that is similar
in Buddhism their lab comes through
meditation in which I experience that
I'm not separate from the universe I'm
not a separate existence that has to
struggle against the rest of the world
it was that I am an aspect of this
totality I am protected in it I'm safe I
am free of anxiety I've learned when I
am that then I can reach out to other
beings without fear without prejudice
and without intentions that is love
belieber
you